hey what is up guys mkbhd here and what
i'm about to show you is a render of the
motorola x phone based on actually
confirmed specs and information
there you go oh the motorola x phone it
seems like it's been rumored since the
day google bought and started to control
and operate motorola mobility but that's
really all we've heard so far isn't it
for that it'll launch this summer with
the latest version of android keylime pi
prefer that it'll have just the right
screen size with very little or no bezel
prefer that i might even have
customizable hardware or let you be able
to pick your parts like you can with
certain other gadgets before that it'll
have a touch sensitive back for the
possibility of some crazy new gestures
that will be built into the newest
version of android we've even heard that
the x phone could have a wooden case
option we have heard so many rumors
about this motorola x phone i want to
tell you a little bit of a story a
little bit of story here on march 1st of
this year guy kawasaki was hired into
google to advise motorola mobility after
that acquisition and that was a pretty
big deal at the time a couple of days
later guy kawasaki posts on google plus
a video on youtube of a porsche sort of
build your own car program that they're
having where you can basically pick all
the different parts that you want to go
into your porsche instead of picking
between some predetermined options and
the caption he put was wouldn't it be
neat if you could personalize your
smartphone like this
huh
huh the comment section went nuts is
this a hint what do you know what does
this mean about the x phone stop playing
with my emotions they absolutely went
insane basically assuming that he's
talking about the x phone as if this
means anything pertaining to what he
does at motorola so guy kawasaki answers
i'm just asking a hypothetical question
oh
okay
what else do you know about the x phone
thanks for the hint are we going to be
able to pick our own parts for the
motorola x phone huh there's got to be a
hypothetical answer to the hypothetical
question right it's hard to imagine
customization on this level will be
possible or even viable in a cell phone
stop
stop
i'm just a porsche fan who works for
motorola
cue the news outlets guy kawasaki hints
at possible hardware customization for
the x phone motorola x phone will have
customizable hardware hints guy kawasaki
motorola handset will be customizable
guy kawasaki hints
what
okay here's the thing about the motorola
x phone
it didn't say anything about x phone in
that post or in any of the actual
confirmed information the thing about
the x phone is stop it it doesn't exist
the motorola x phone is a figment of our
imaginations and our desires and a
manifestation of what we want to see in
a smartphone i mean there's no reason
any of this stuff that's been rumored
could never happen i mean some of it
could maybe actually happen but who
cares i get questions every single day
about uh i have the galaxy s3 and i'm
waiting to upgrade should i get the
galaxy s4 or the htc one or should i
wait for the motorola x phone
that's not a thing so since there is no
such thing as a motorola x phone and
since it is just a figment of our
imaginations of what we want to see in a
phone that's a collaboration between
google and motorola i challenge you this
for the next month
or at least for the next two weeks
ignore any motorola x phone headlines
and rumor posts you may see just ignore
them you're gonna see a headline about
what could be a maybe possible awesome
breakthrough feature in the motorola x
phone or some other new leak not really
about what could also happen to the
motorola x phone uh and we've even seen
those as recently as yesterday just
ignore them why would you ignore them
you say because the motorola x phone
can't be everything when a collaboration
finally does happen between motorola and
google it won't have all of the things
we've seen in all the rumors and leaks
and that's because well that's just
unrealistic and the point of that is
some people are inevitably going to be
disappointed by the fact that there's
not that favorite feature that they're
waiting for i don't know if you guys
remember project road runner in this
supposed leak we had project butter and
android 4.1 we were expecting to see
project road runner to improve battery
life in 4.2 it was a leak it was
completely made up someone actually
published that as a thing that was going
to probably happen it never happened and
people got mad at google for not doing
it eric raven's craft of android police
really did put it best he said i love
talking about android and the future of
android i love imagining what's coming
next and i even love predicting things
and being wrong it's fun it's a learning
experience tech inspires us to do this
very thing when it turns dark however is
when we suddenly start acting like
google owes us something
yes that is exactly what i get pissed
about sometimes so let's just relax and
let the evolution of smartphones take
place before our very eyes and enjoy the
flagships that already do exist there
are some awesome phones out there that
we should be picking between now instead
of worrying about this motorola x phone
unless you actually do work for motorola
in which case
you should be working your tail off to
make sure that next flagship phone is
awesome phone either way that's
basically it that's my little rant talk
about the x phone ignore the rumors
thanks for watching this has just been a
quick little rant video and if you
enjoyed it definitely feel free to hit
the thumbs up button below or the
subscribe button further below which is
where you can click to see the rest of
the videos that i upload either way
thanks for watching and i'll talk to you
guys in the next video peace
you